y'en a une qui est au coeur d'une grosse
polémique justement c'est charline van
den acker norris de france inter qui a
trois roulent en publiant hier sur son
compte twitter à sketch dans lequel elle
décide une moustache d'hitler sur une
affiche d'eric zemmour dans la rue
l'énorme majorité des internautes ont
été choqués par cette vidéo est ce que
vous pensez qu'elle doit s'excuser
qu'elle doit être retirée de l'antenne
de france inter c'est je pense
inadmissible en plus elle est
complètement abrutis elle poste ça le
jour de l'ue qui vous remet maintenant
une façon elle voilà c'est incroyable
regarder que ça et c'est fou que france
inter n'est pas réagi je vous le dis
c'est le service public là vraiment il
faut vraiment que nous sommes sincères
fois c'est incroyable regarder ça un
petit jeu à faire avec les affiches de
ricou partout en france
ces 56
voilà
un plus original que cela
d'ailleurs elle a changé son prénom
le hasard a fait que le gars qui a
brocardé macro hitler a été condamné à
une amende aujourd'hui c'est ça donc
c'est ça qui est incroyable et elle a
lille il ya eu une polémique à trouver
sans bien sûr que ça me choquerait
choquant mais le problème c'est toujours
pareil c'est le deux poids deux mesures
c'est dans certains ont le droit d'être
antisémite d'être raciste mais parce
qu'ils sont de gauche ou de l'extrême
gauche on dit absolument rien en
revanche qu on s'est imaginé par exemple
à un président nourrir quelqu'un qui
seraient conduits à la présidence et qui
seraient noirs et à qui un journaliste
de ces news dessinerait des chaînes aux
pieds pour dire voilà c'est marrant ça
lui rappelle l' esclavage à tous ces
gens là ça a repeint ces gens là se sont
ré sauter comme des cabris durant vous
avez défendu
lundi à la haye les pattes afin
d'identifier
la toile et enfin bon de secondes sur
loeb on surfe outils et c'est bien pour
tout le monde je veux qu'on parle de ça
deux choses déjà là la première c'est
que c'est pas qu'une journaliste est les
humoristes sur ses principaux là mais
non c'est pas une histoire drôle c'est
par mois de carême pour moi le mec qu'a
car il asséné alors c'est pourquoi pas
non mais c'est pas à moi de décider ce
que c'est drôle où ce n'est pas drôle
c'est une humoriste avec le sait quelque
chose l'élu de gauche c'est parce que
j'y ai plein air célébrée
tous les signaler aux méchants le
condamne donc vous que je ne condamne
pas que ça soit une caricature ou que ça
soit une humour et bien sûr
mais revenir à eric zemmour que je
considère qui est antisémite sur les
sorties qu'il a sorti l'arrêt en tant
que juifs et moi même dit que péta bce
avait sauvé des juifs de france ça c'est
la première chose et la deuxième chose
il a eu une grosse polémique le moment
où mohamed merah a été enterré en
algérie
et tout public
messin médias jean messia l'égyptien je
considère
que tout pays service
des mecs
d'abord c'est pas du tout drôle mais
c'est purement et simplement d'
incitation à la haine raciale et oui
d'antisémitisme monsieur vous devez
condamné mais non vous n'êtes plus
crédible monsieur parce que très
franchement ce qu'elle a fait je ne
comprends pas que les associations ne
porte pas plainte le service public doit
la virée elle discrédite tout ce qui est
animations journalisme c'est
pas du tout sûr eric zemmour ou quoi
c'est cette action-là elle déshonore la
france est partie habitée
on va parler vraiment il a pris 3
millions d'amendé pour avoir fait un
sketch qui tirent pour plus drôle à
l'appeler la personne n'a rien dit rien
c'est ça qui passe son temps à digérer
et et ils ont dit ce matin chez pro
vérité c'est que quand on est de gauche
on peut tout dire on à la carte on fait
tout et n'importe quoi
y'a quand même de dire
la vérité